how's it going guys
thank you man how are you
really fantastic okay so complete mess
we have so much to talk about uh but
complete mess this uh first of all tell
me about the song tell me what you
wanted to say where did it come from
there's some big hard-hitting questions
there
um
that sounds sarcastic but it actually is
um
it came from the band going uh taking a
little time in
uh
covert when we didn't see each other for
a long time and then we went out to an
isolated place in joshua tree
and sort of just went out with no
expectations and we wanted to see what
the band would sound like just us
writing and producing
so we went out and did just that and
came out with the first single um pretty
pretty quickly after we went out there
so it was an amazing feeling and um
this song really sums up where the
band's at where we want to be and
hopefully people connect to it the way
we have you know being able to sort of
have this be the track that is entirely
written entirely produced by you guys
what sort of feeling does that give you
was it like sweet freedom was it nervous
like what where where did you guys sort
of go into this and then come out of it
with uh with having just sort of
complete control over uh over a track
yeah i mean it's uh more of a feeling of
progression uh from our perspective it's
a natural evolution of our process
uh it's a liberation of a process we've
experienced many great collaborators in
our in our career but um what we
realized was some of the most important
collaborators are right in front of us
in the band and um we've always been
really driven songwriters very
hard-working songwriters to to to
capture concepts that will make you know
five seconds of summer a legendary group
um you know we work hard towards that
every day so it was a natural evolution
of our workflow
and the way we wanted to write lyrics
and and make our track beds and expose
the best parts of this band to the world
uh you've heard this before with with
bands who have been you know in in in
deep with labels and a lot of hands and
a lot of minds on the the sort of
creative process where
getting to this point being able to sort
of write and produce it your entire
selves uh it's almost a necessity for
bands that they have to do this they
have to get to a point of where they do
it on their own did you guys feel that
it was a necessity
um
i think in order to attain
some form of um longevity
that is meaningful in a philosophical
way just to a human being
um i think independence in the creative
process
creates a more individual um
and unique perspective and set of ideas
that you come up with
um because everybody's story is unique
and the more you tap into that
uniqueness of your
way through this world and transferring
that into lyrics and then releasing that
to a wonderful fan base that we have
that's that that's true success to us
you know
when's the last time either of you were
a complete mess over someone oh my gosh
every day mate
that's that's it oh my gosh
yeah i think um this song
really
conceptually touches on learning who
really matters to you and why
and uh it's the kind of um
song that kind of evaluates what um your
personal values are when you choose who
is in your life
yeah
and uh um
it's been a tough couple of years for
everyone but when it came to writing and
the creative process some people at the
beginning of all of this shut down and
some people really dove in and they
found creativity instantly
where were you guys sort of on that
spectrum
we both made solo records yeah so i
guess the latter
but more out of um well for me
personally i can't speak for luke but
for me it was um
you know i never went to university or i
never went to college i came right out
of high school and on to this stage with
these guys
and for me i was like okay what have i
got left to learn in music and i have a
lot of things to learn and one of them
was engineering
creating a record recording it yourself
and i did all that at my house so
um i was just learning about you know in
a deeper level whilst i wasn't on tour
how to do what i love and that was kind
of my uh my inspiration
when you go back and look at a song like
she looks so perfect what is your
relationship with the with the old music
that's the funnest song on earth yeah
we
it's it's funny because i think
now looking back at it it's such a
um we look at it a lot differently it's
such a blessing and it's such a youthful
great song we love it has like a life of
its own you know people still
um
love that song for a bunch of different
reasons and like people attach to it as
like a time in their lives and i think
to be able to play that
live now and amongst a bunch of other
songs and like it to be able to take
people back to that moment is really
cool sometimes when we play that song
now we look at each other and go whoa
still love this one yeah still like oh
that's good because you know what it's
like you guys have had favorite bands
over the years where you know as the
years go on and like you guys
celebrating 10 years together you know
sometimes your favorite band they don't
even love the old stuff anymore
that's so true and i think
that is an internal healing process of
whatever they did to get to where they
are or whatever but you know we as a
group really try to manifest positive
feelings towards every song we've
released and realize that our individual
perspectives don't affect how people
really love that music still they really
want to come see it live and we do our
best to respect and honor that you know
yeah uh so the soon to be announced
album um
what can you tell fans about it
it's just ambitious five sauce it it's
it's us a fantastic ambitious one yes
just us trying to still expand to a
place that um you know one day we still
dream of playing stadiums to our
beautiful audience we we still
um think about putting those intentions
into our music we still want to you know
uh show ourselves as lyricists and we
want to show progression to our fans you
know that's the main thing
and what is it about you guys that you
know made 10 years possible
because a lot of that's a long time in
music for a band yeah i think
particularly the way that we started i
think um
you know it doesn't always go this way i
think it's just the intention into the
um the basics
really boringly it's uh into the
songwriting and being a great live act i
think it's
putting like really putting those at the
forefront of our whole career even since
we're you know 15 16 like that was such
an important thing to us and just
growing on it every time and coming back
um
hopefully stronger and better at them
yeah
and watching each other grow and grow up
i have to imagine is an incredible thing
to sort of be around uh luke
congratulations on the engagements
mm-hmm thank you yeah
i don't i don't know i don't know where
you did that but that looked like it
took some planning to get to wherever
you guys were
yeah it took a minute but i had i had a
bit of time it was in it wasn't covered
so it uh had some had some time in my
hands
are you the are you the uh full-on
hands-on planning kind of guy or are you
the tell me when to show up and where
and i will be there kind of guy
i
i feel like i'm not a very good planner
and it took all
all the skill sets i have to plan a
night like that it uh took everything
out of me so i think for that night i
was very hands-on and it was lots and
lots of planning
um
but usually i'm not very good at
planning stuff
and and i don't know i i i don't know
whether it's is it cool if a band plays
their own wedding or is that not cool
dude i was about to say something like
that i was like he didn't even have a
drum kit set up
for me you know
i was like waiting i i'm so down to play
weddings for these it would be amazing i
think it's very cool maybe my winning i
like it
yeah
uh
and again with the with the cool thing
i'm so i i don't even know like is there
like do people do like
bachelor parties anymore like is that
happening are you those kinds of guys
um we're not in the classic sense
bachelor party guys
um but i don't know after the changes in
the world and everything we're very
relaxed and chill we love to get
together i love barbecues now because i
don't know where that came from i turned
25 and all of a sudden the australian
dude didn't mean like
right now i'm cooking a barbecue every
second day but we keep it pretty chill
um we're just kind of trying to keep
healthy to get back on the road you know
so we're not really partying very much
anymore
we we all got very used to when we were
at home during all this we all got very
used to our stuff and i'm wondering what
it's like for you guys right now
thinking about going back out onto the
road having to leave all that stuff that
we all got very used to
it's daunting it definitely is it's such
a immense
like genuine excitement to go out on the
road and be able to do what we did for
so many years and couldn't do for
several years um
so that is it's a massive excitement but
it's going to be a bit of a change you
know i've gotten pretty i've gotten
pretty used to being like
pretty homebody you know there's the
first as long as we've been at home like
even in the first couple months like we
hadn't been anywhere along since
i don't know we were in australia before
we left for the band so it was
you know i've gotten used to it now so
we'll see how we go it'll be fun and
it's and it's the same goodbye to people
as well like are you making sure now
that you have sort of more chances to go
home or more chances to bring people on
the road with you
of course man um
you know because people have given us
this opportunity to be this band that
exists for 10 years and
all these things you start to think okay
how do i bring my family into this life
how do i bring my friends and and how do
i incorporate the people that you know
really feel my soul
into what we do and how do i share this
with people
um and that's at the top of the
priorities for me
uh and uh
what is something
about you
an interest a love whatever it is that
we will never hear on a song luke i'll
start with you oh jeez
an interest that will you'll never hear
man like something you're into that
you're like man i love that but nobody
can know that i will never write about
that
that's that's a real tough one
i don't think it's going to be
it's nothing to be embarrassed about but
we're never going to be able to release
the song like heart of the country by
paul mccartney or something we're not
going to be able to do like you know
luke and i grew up on in farmland
so if you do a song about the horses
chickens and the sheep i mean they just
don't think the fans would really like
it very much they wouldn't believe it
too they wouldn't believe it no they
wouldn't i
that's not going to make it into a verse
and it's just not pop gold you know
how often do they how often do the farm
boys come out when you guys are together
dude you'd be surprised you basically
switches on naturally i don't know
what's you know i don't know we could be
in la for 30 years that we wouldn't
change you know so
like but um you got the farm boys duo
from fonson
is it the kind of thing of where when
one starts it just triggers everybody
else is that the way that it goes it's
an aussie accent thing the accent just
gets thicker and thicker and thicker you
know better
yeah it's it's ingrained in us you know
that's our origins but you know
and uh having been now together for as
long as you have you've had to navigate
so much of this i'm sure through the
advice of really incredible people
around you but what's the one thing that
you weren't told at the beginning of all
of this maybe how to survive as a band
how to how to maintain sanity that you
had to figure out on your own
maintain sanity yeah honestly the last
um ironically because we were very lucky
the last um
couple years to be able to stay home you
know and have a place um to sort of
uh
reside in um so i think the last couple
years have been really um i don't know
informative to
like being home and like doing some
uh for the state of the world being very
not normal we did you know a lot of
people did you know making bread and
like gardening and all that sort of
stuff i think
uh i don't know it's just been kind of
nice to be
at home for a bit and try and figure
some of that stuff out and go out in the
road and have a new sort of sense of
determination and gratitude towards it
yeah the plan never changes it's still
self-discovery and how do i exist in a
in a joyful way you know in this world
that's the that's the goal you know
and uh before i let you guys go
fans as you know have missed live shows
they have missed you guys i can only
imagine you have missed fans just as
much as they've missed you uh what do
you want to say to the fans who are just
dying to see you guys live finally again
oh my goodness well we're just as
excited as they are you know to go out
and play songs people and we have a new
album on the way and i think it's going
to be really um
fun to sort of discover that together in
a live experience and yeah yeah in many
ways we want to show them that no matter
what happens we'll keep
keep trying to do this we'll keep trying
to deliver music and art and we'll keep
true to the path no matter what happens
in the world you know because we
understand how special it is and it's
worth holding on to no matter what
happens you know so we're looking
forward to showing them that and it's
been a while any songs you've forgotten
how to play
mate don't even
definitely a couple it's a worry we've
got some rehearsing to do for sure
that's awesome thank you guys so much i
really appreciate it congratulations on
everything and hopefully next time we do
this we can be in the same room thank
you sir very nice
you